Now, how do you feel
about the first live
birth that's podcasted?
Oh.
(laughing)
I think that's something
we should talk about.
Look, I see, think of it, look,
think of the clicks,
think of the merchandise.
Merchandise?
Yeah, you know, we shoot video
for all these things now, too.
That's what the ring light's for.
Yeah, no audio, no audio only,
But just, you know us.
And then (imitates baby crying)!
(all laugh)
Oh, man!
In the background we can hear
Tak breaking boards. Crack!
(both laugh)
Crack! Crack!
He's doing karate in the room?
Yeah, yeah!
Umbilical cord?
I got this! Whack!
He takes out a throwing star
and just cuts the umbilical cord.
(Conan imitates a throwing
star whizzing through the air)
Oh my God.